hoy es el primer día del año en china el
año del tigre que marca también el
inicio del festival de primavera son las
vacaciones más relevantes del calendario
nacional cuando los chinos se reúnen en
familia y estas vacaciones suponen cada
año la mayor migración humana del mundo
aunque en esta edición como en las dos
anteriores el número se va a reducir
considerablemente porque varias
provincias han recomendado que no se
viaje debido a la pandemia este viernes
además empiezan en pekín los juegos
olímpicos y en este clima de
celebraciones se han acentuado los
controles más de 2 millones de vecinos
de fontana y un barrio periférico de la
capital fueron analizados la semana
pasada después de haberse detectado
apenas un puñado de casos y los tests se
han extendido en los últimos días al
centro de la ciudad los juegos suponen
un reto mayúsculo a la política de
'tolerancia cero' del gobierno más de
200 personas que han llegado en los
últimos días para participar en los
juegos han dado positivo entre ellos
varios deportistas